hello everyone
and welcome my name is mandi boraj
and i'm the head of product for
industrial ai in google's cloud business
i lead a portfolio of artificial
intelligence products that help solve
some of the most complex
and hard industrial problems at global
scale
today i'm going to talk about three
things
first the current state of automation
and industrial efficiency and how
artificial intelligence is revealing
an entirely new universe of
possibilities
second google cloud's approach to
bringing these ai technologies to the
market
and third our deploy anywhere
methodology that
helps achieve the impact of ai at a
global enterprise scale
let me first begin by sharing how we are
approaching our strategy
to help industrial enterprise customers
transform themselves
so our strategy hinges on three pillars
first is to provide tools and
technologies to connect your physical
assets
and workforce to the cloud
second is to bring both your existing
analytics tools
and new analytics capabilities that
augment human decision making
and third to drive end-to-end automation
of key industrial processes
by embedding our differentiated ai
technologies
into the industrial workflows
as part of this session i'll focus only
on our ai capabilities
we're applying ai to help some of the
largest enterprise companies transform
their businesses
we're helping the largest airlines
better plan their schedules
aircraft utilization and manage
unforeseen operational disruptions
we're helping logistic companies achieve
better fleet utilization
route planning and maximize the life of
their assets
we're helping automotive companies bring
their vehicle telemetry data to the
cloud
and preempt component failure and
recalls in real time
we'll be discussing two manufacturing
focused solutions
adaptive controls and visual inspection
in more detail
in this session here are some of the
companies that are trusting google to
transform their industrial operations
and businesses
using ai and machine learning
technologies
before i get into the details of ai
technologies
i want to take a brief talk about where
we are
in the broader industrial automation
evolution
for decades advances in automated
controls and systems have made
industrial processes and supply chains
highly efficient but every subsequent
advance in efficiency
has demanded greater investment while
yielding
leaner returns to a point of flattening
of the curve
the staggering complexity of the
industrial environment is now combined
with a dynamic and uncertain environment
like the one we finding ourselves right
now
where there's dramatic volatility in
market forces
disrupted supply chains and retail
channels uncertainty of demand
and cost pressures to stay afloat the
current industrial systems are turning
out too brittle
and unadaptable narrow in their search
for
efficiency gains with years of
systemized rules and heuristics
layers of operational buffers and
inefficiencies
capped and accrued by human expertise
these constraints make industrial
systems a great candidate for ai and
machine learning based solutions
for machine learning based systems each
layer of complexity
is another dimension to explore for
hidden correlations
allowing every aspect of an industrial
environment to be analyzed minutely
temporarily and copy naturally
individually
and holistically exploring new action
spaces and uncovering
unfound efficiency gains
these systems can adapt to internal and
external headwinds
and learn to anticipate disruptions
allowing stable autonomous operation
we'll talk through two such examples of
autonomous controls technology
adaptive controls and visual inspection
ai
both aimed at achieving autonomous
process controls
in industrial facilities let's first
talk about industrial adaptive controls
platform
that automates and optimizes closed
closed-loop industrial systems
like the hvac systems or scada control
processing plants
this platform builds on years of
google's research
in reinforcement learning where an ai
agent learns directly from sensory
experience
and develops new knowledge by exploring
the action space and then
optimizes based on the most efficient
future predicted state
with no hand crafted rules a general
purpose learning framework
and general apis to take in sensory
input
and produce set point recommendations
this platform is capable to solve
several industrial optimization problems
it turns out that operating a data
center with concrete actions and
measurable rewards
is a great fit for such a problem modern
data centers especially the large ones
at google
are complex pieces of equipment with
billions of ways of operating them
for example suppose you have a
simplified system with 10 pieces of
equipment
each which has 10 different set points
that's already over 3 million
different permutations keep in mind that
a real data center has
much more than 10 pieces of equipment
they interact with each other in
non-linear manners
while environmental conditions such as
i.t load and weather
are constantly changing adaptive
controls platform has been helping
reduce
energy consumption in google data
centers through direct
autonomous control of hvac systems
so how does this work ai optimizes a
reward function
this could be energy consumption or any
other function expressed as a
mathematical equation of sensors
while adapting to the changing variables
like the building load
and still keep meeting operational
constraints
like building comfort for example
in the data center scenario the ai
evaluates
millions of allowable set point
combinations
predicts future states of energy
consumption
and operational constraints removes
those that
violate equipment or safety constraints
chooses the set points that maximizes
the objective function
returns the recommended set points into
a bms
platform to be implemented directly into
the equipment
the generalizability of this platform
allows a number of industrial processes
and facilities optimization problems
to be solved using this approach imagine
the impact that this could have on the
global energy use in airports
malls corporate buildings waste
reduction in chemical plants
smelters metal processing facilities
all while achieving higher industrial
output
another problem space where we are
applying google's ai capabilities
is industrial defect detection google's
computer vision capabilities are
consistently rated as the best in the
industry we've made these vision ai
capabilities available through
our general apis that use pre-trained
machine learning models
trained on billions of images and
through auto ml platform
where you can bring your own image data
sets to train custom vision models
now we're taking this one step further
we are partnering with some of the
largest manufacturers of the world to
bring
high accuracy premium models for defect
detection
starting with assembly inspection and
cosmetic inspection
in an end-to-end automated solution
we've created a dedicated breakout
session to cover the technical
breakthroughs of this technology
delivered by one of my teammates ying
fei please do check it out
lg has applied our machine learning
models to achieve 99.9
accuracy for cosmetic defect detection
in their glass display panels
similarly global foundries have used our
machine learning models for silicon
wafer defect detection
achieving 95 percent accuracy across
hundreds of machine learning models
deployed in their factories
which makes for a good segue into our
final topic
of scaling ai at a global industrial
scale
it's one thing running a pilot on a
small subsystem in a sandbox
and it's a completely different thing
transforming an entire industrial
workflow
to run autonomously using ai working
across
multiple ai products use cases and
deployment environments
we've honed the approach of deploying ai
at a large scale
we've come to embrace that the real
world environments are
highly complex heterogeneous
unstructured and fragmented this reality
has
made us design a deploy anywhere
approach
for machine learning our goal is to
provide
interoperability across all computing
platforms
legacy systems and devices from cloud
hybrid to edge from microcontrollers
cpus gpus tpus to clusters of servers
industrial equipment like high-speed
cameras and drones
and hardware supporting mqtt and opc ua
industrial standards
in working with the largest enterprise
customers
we've seen the challenge of managing
hundreds of machine learning models in
production environment
therefore we developed managed services
that allow
any kind of machine learning workload be
it a time series
an image or a video machine learning
model to be deployed on
any kind of edge device
these services allow you to version
control monitor performance
and retrain models across a large fleet
of edge devices
you can learn more about these
deployment platforms in their dedicated
breakout sessions
you can also connect with any of our
machine learning specialists or contact
us
through our website to get started
finally i feel excited that ai as a
discipline has reached a stage
where it's having a direct and
measurable impact
on scaling our collective human output
our technologies are truly living up to
their promise
of furthering our progress as a society
and creating a more promising future
thank you once again for joining and i
hope you'll enjoy the other next
sessions
have a great day
you